r si la parole est un monsieur sylvain
berrios monsieur le premier ministre
les maires sont les premiers élus au
contact les français ils sont sollicités
chaque jour par les associations pour
des crèches pour les affaires scolaires
pour la sécurité le logement l'aide
sociale la propreté l'urbanisme ou
encore la voirie il accompagne les
français tout au long de leur vie de la
naissance jusqu'au décès en passant par
le mariage
or les maires monsieur prémunissent sont
en colère ils ont manifesté à l'instant
devant l'assemblée nationale
ils sont en colère parce que le
gouvernement a choisi de les désigner
comme des adversaires
vous avez fait voter une loi sur le
non-cumul pour que les mères quittent
l'assemblée vous ne réussirez pas les
faire taire pour autant vous n'arrivez
pas à vous quel budget de l'état alors
vous décidé de couper la notation aux
communes mais vous augmenter le salaire
des fonctionnaires en 2010 cette année
d'une élection
pendant ce temps les maires doivent
réduire les manifestations augmenter les
tarifs des piscines des cantines
renoncer à des investissements
importants
les communes se serre la ceinture vous
leur demandez des finances une réforme
des rythmes scolaires absurde et
inopérante pour les enfants des communes
sont étranglés par les emprunts toxiques
vous choisissez les banques contre les
communes vous parlez vous perdez les
départementales et bien vous rajoutez
une couche millefeuille administratif
en choisissant de découper les
territoires dans le secret des cabinets
doré de matignon vous voulez donner des
gages à l'ailé gauche du ps vous
désigner les maires comme responsable du
logement social vous livrer les maires à
la vindicte populaire voulait
sanctionner comme aux pires heures de la
terreur simplement parce qu'ils ne
pensent pas comme vous monsieur le
premier ministre nous les maires qui
sommes encore ici quelques-uns
parlementaire sommes-nous les
adversaires de ce gouvernement
merci la parole est à monsieur andré
vallini secrétaire des tâches
j'ai de la réforme territoriale merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
berrios je rencontre comme vous beaucoup
de mères tout au long de de la semaine
je me déplace dans tous les départements
de france j'étais encore samedi dernier
au congrès des maires du tarn
je rencontre des maires préoccupé c'est
vrai je rencontre des maires soucieux de
l'intérêt général de leur population qui
sont les les hussards de la république
est depuis longtemps et je leur explique
que le gouvernement est conscient de
l'effort qu'il leur demande 11 milliards
de baisses de dotations sur trois ans
sur un plan d'économies global de 50
milliards c'est 20 % 20 % c'est le poids
de la dépense publique locale dans la
dépense publique globale donc cet effort
et proportionnée à ce que représentent
les finances locales dans les finances
publiques de l'autre pays deuxième
élément pour que cet effort important
je le répète soit équitablement répartis
nous avons renforcé la péréquation c'est
à dire la solidarité entre les communes
les plus riches et les moins favorisés
les communes les plus en difficulté et
celles qui ont plus de ressources que la
moyenne
troisième élément très important
l'investissement public local ils
représentent 70% de l'investissement
public en france
nous y sommes très attentifs le premier
ministre a annoncé des mesures notamment
en matière de tva
nous avons reçu autour du premier
ministre avec christian eckert la mf il
ya quinze jours un nouveau rendez vous
est pris en juillet parce que nous
voulons continuer à prendre des mesures
notamment pour les territoires ruraux
mais aussi pour les territoires urbains
monsieur le député du val-de-marne pour
aider les communes à continuer à
investir car c'est très important pour
l'équipe it et économique de notre pays